I wanted to use this video to go a
little bit more in-depth on the treaty
on the terms of the Treaty of Versailles
because these will become relevant as we
start talking about the rise of Hitler
and the Nazis in the start of World War
two so just as a review we've already
talked about the Treaty of Versailles
placing the war guilt on the Germans is
saying they were to blame for World War
two which is considered to be a
controversial statement obviously many
many other actors were involved in world
war two as well
the one justification for placing war
guilt on Germany is that they were very
aggressive in declaring war on both
Russia and France at the at the break of
World War one and really caused it to be
a europe-wide war the other term is
we've already talked about is it
diminished their armed forces to a
hundred thousand men they're Navy to
fifteen thousand men really a basic
scaffold almost really more of a police
force than Armed Forces the Treaty of
Versailles also said that they could not
form a union with Austria no no
integration or Union union with Austria
obviously there was fears of Germany
trying to create a more kind of
pan-german state Austria they do speak
German they are ethnically German and on
top of that we have all of the lost
German colonies so the colonies in
Africa the colonies in Asia these were
all get taken away from Germany
but of particular interest I want to
talk about the territorial changes that
took place and this map is a little bit
cleaner than the one we looked at the in
the last video on the Paris Peace
Conference in the Treaty of Versailles
so first you have just the territorial
losses fart for Germany so right over
here we already talked about Poland
being carved out of the former German
Empire and the former Russian Empire
after after the Bolsheviks took over
we're not talking about the USSR and
this chunk right over here of Western
Prussia that is in this red color we do
this in magenta this was given over for
the new state this is given over for the
new state of Poland and parts right over
here of Silesia right over here were
given over Poland this part of Silesia
down here was given to Czechoslovakia
this area right up here was made a free
State the Free State of Danzig but that
was also taken from former German
territory we already talked about Alsace
and Lorraine which is this area in
contention between France and Germany
for many many many years was now given
back was now given back to France
Belgium some of German territory was
given over to Belgium as well you have
this little section right over here
called North's Lessig that was given
over to Denmark now on top of that
territory that was given over and
actually over here too you have this
little part this upper tip right over
here of Prussia was given over or was
actually taken by little a Lithuanian
was initially given to France but it was
taken by Lithuania so that was all the
formal German territorial losses but
then on top of that they had to give
over reparations and part of this
reparation process was to give the Saar
region or not to give there sergeant but
let the Tsar reason be occupied by the
Allies and the reason why the Saar
region was of interest is that was a
major coal producing region of Germany
and it was a lie it was occupied by the
Allies and then all the coal was shipped
over to France apparently to make up for
all of the losses the the the cold
production that France had lost during
World War one on top of that none of the
Allies were interested in kind of
another invasion by Germany so you had
an occupant occupation and then
demilitarization of the Rhineland and
the Rhineland included this part of
Germany that was west of the Rhine River
all of this region right over here and a
50 kilometer strip east of the Rhine
River so Germany was not allowed to
militarize this and this will become
very relevant once we have the Nazis
come to power because they test the
resolve of the Allies as we'll see they
they do start to militarize the
Rhineland and see what the what
what kind of the strength of the allies
so these are the major territorial gains
over on top of the things that we've
talked about here above and beyond that
obviously the reparations loomed large
and the reparations weren't just in pure
dollar terms the reparations were valued
if in modern 2013 dollars it roughly 400
or so billion dollars but they don't
ever get fully paid but the reparations
are irrelevant obviously in terms of the
occupation of this Saar region right
over here and then we'll see in 1923 you
have spiraling inflation in Weimar
Germany why maar Germany's the the
German Republic that emerges out of
World War one named after the city in
which the Constitution was drafted and
when they're not able to pay the
reparations in 1923 you actually have
Fred the French occupying the rural
region in Germany which is another area
that of of coal production and steel
production roughly in this region right
over here and between the the the
hyperinflation that you have in Germany
and this humiliation of France taking
even more significant fraction of
Germans Germany's industrial or coal and
steel production this is part of the
fuel that allows the Nazi the National
Socialist or the social or the Nazis to
get more and more of a following in an
eventual attempt a coup d'etat they
pushed in the end of 1923 that's a
failed pooched but it gives them a lot
more support than they would have
otherwise had